hey at seven my youtube channel has just
passed half a million views and I'm so
excited I just wanted to make a quick
video to thank everybody for your
support when I first started doing the
videos I had no idea what I was doing I
did it because I found that was a visual
learner and I like seeing things that
are just reading something or hearing
something i like seeing things in a
video and i didn't necessarily get a lot
from the videos that were out there at
the time and so I thought hey I got to
make my own videos I didn't have a
business model I didn't know how it was
gonna work out I didn't spend a lot of
money everything was bootstrap if you
look at my first videos who were they
were really bad the content was pretty
good but the quality of the production
was terrible camera shaking lights are
low just bad you know sometimes I want
to remove those from my my channel if
you go back to the beginning but people
still watch them and give them likes and
comment on them and say they appreciate
it so i guess for our own harshest
critic anyway it's gone from the point
of doing a video a month and not doing
it that often and not you know really
knowing what i'm doing with it yet to
actually building now i'm doing two
videos a day and so it's been such a fun
experience to go through that whole
process and be able to share my thoughts
with you guys and answer your questions
and just like anything else when you're
first getting started in a new business
or a new line or new way to grow your
business i always recommend starting
small testing see if it's for you don't
go out and spend a ton of money see if
it works if you're enjoying it see if
you're getting feedback from it and
people want you to continue then it's
worth putting more time effort dollars
into it to make it grow and the youtube
stuff has been so much fun for me i film
on a wednesday afternoon typically i get
my phone out see all the questions that
have been asked i used to do a lot of
the questions by email someone who asked
me a question i'd answer back and i
thought hey there's got to be a better
way to reach more people and help other
people have the same problem so i
started the videos and wednesdays have
become one of my favorite days of the
week because i know I get to sit down
and even though I'm just talking to the
camera right now I know people are
watching and I'm able to help them and I
hopefully help motivate you to keep
going with your business and not feel so
alone and not feel so hopeless with
what's going on with your company
because we're all going through the same
things and the best part of my day
really every day is when I wake up I go
to the computer I make myself my
breakfast which is usually lentils with
some cut up hot dogs in it sounds gross
right but it's actually pretty good my
mom has some an awesome homemade lentil
recipe that I use so it's awesome and I
load up my computer and I look at my
youtube comments and every day there's
like 20 comments in there people who
have loved the videos asking questions
saying keep going and that fuels me to
keep going making more videos for you
and so I just want to say thank you half
a million views is all is is great I
want to get to the next step hopefully
you guys will keep asking questions keep
giving me likes keep leaving comments
below and that will fuel me to keep
going and hopefully together we can all
build massive successes with our
businesses my goal is to help a billion
entrepreneurs and you guys are help
helping part of that movement happen so
thank you for those of you watching as
you always do please leave a thumbs up
below thank you so much for my half a
million views and if you have a question
for your business I'd love to try to
answer for you I always read the
comments as you just heard me say so
leave it in the comments section below
any question you have your company I
always read those I'll try to respond to
you thank you guys so much here's to the
next half million views and good luck
with your business